hola hola cómo están todos
vamos a hacerlo un poquito más fuerte
cómo están todos
oigan pues un placer estar el día de hoy
aquí antes que nada quisiera aclarar que
el tema que voy a dar realmente no es el
tema que escogí me explico la verdad es
que cuando me dieron la oportunidad de
presentar este tema
el que más me resonaba era el tema que
se titulaba ríndete entonces empecé a
documentarme y realmente me llamó la
atención este tema porque dije desde
chicos nos preparan para ser ganadores
nos preparan para triunfar para nunca
perder inclusive que cuando haya una
negociación de ganar-ganar que tú seas
el que haya ganado más que la otra
persona este fue un pensamiento que
incluso también se me inculcó cuando
estaba niño me decían louis si vas a
hacer rateros es el mejor ratero que
nunca te atrapen vengo de iztapalapa de
alguna manera tiene sentido
pero ese es el problema no que venga de
iztapalapa sino que nos preparan tanto
para ganar que no sabemos perder y esto
inclusive en nuestra vida personal no
soportamos que nos hayamos equivocado
que hayamos fracasado y no queremos ver
esos errores era como cuando llevábamos
una torta de huevo a la escuela en
nuestra mochila y se echaba a perder
sabíamos que teníamos que sacar esa
torta de huevo meter sacar esa torta de
huevo meter la mano embarrarnos de la
sustancia en la que se hubiera
convertido esa torta de huevo verla
olerla y sacarla de nuestra mochila para
que ya no no ya no la cargamos durante
toda nuestra estancia en la escuela mi
nombre es luis se licitó rey en youtube
soy uno de esos tantos youtubers que hoy
abundan tanto en la red obviamente soy
de los más guapos de los más humildes
más sencillos
y el tema que se voy a dar se llama no
te lo tomes tan en serio porque cambia
de tema
porque revisando las redes sociales me
encontré con un tuit de 20 que es un
youtube
y que seguramente conocen
y el en un en un tuit puso que ella
había dado una conferencia que se
llamaba ríndete entonces tenía dos
opciones o me la jugaba con la misma
conferencia o
optaba por otro tema al final opté por
este tema que se llama no te lo tomes
tan en serio y siento que desde chicos
nos tomamos las cosas muy a la ligera
somos libres yo me entretenía pateando
un bote de plástico una caja de cartón
se convertía en mi poli juego favorito y
de repente empiezas a crecer y el ego te
dice sé exitoso sé millonario has algo
importante y no lo empezamos a creer nos
empezamos a creer que somos los roles de
nuestro trabajo nos empezamos a creer
que somos los títulos que están en las
paredes de nuestra casa nos empezamos a
creer que somos los halagos que somos
las críticas que somos lo que traemos
puesto que somos lo que traemos en los
bolsillos o lo que compramos y nos
olvidamos de lo que realmente somos nos
tomamos las cosas muy en serio no sé si
les ha pasado que de repente hacen una
reunión en su casa y se pierde algo y
entonces empiezan a buscar por dónde
está en este cajón ya revise tres veces
pero chance por arte de magia si está
y abren y no está la carretera y que
empezamos a hacer empezamos a buscar
culpables empezamos a juzgar y decimos
quién fue quién fue claro fue mi suegra
le caigo mal sí sí desde chicos cuando
andaba con su hija no le gustaba para
que fuera su pareja y ahorita me quiere
molestar abajo de la mesa claro o no no
fue mi hermano apenas me dijo me dijo
que necesitaba dinero y así quiere salir
de sus deudas no cómo es posible que
siendo de la misma
ya sé quién ya sé quién fue este la
vecina sí sí sí sí se enojó por lo del
lugar de estacionamiento y ahora me
quiere molestar de esa manera sí hasta
sentir una rara vibra cuando estuve en
la reunión si hasta me ha de estar
haciendo brujería pero conmigo no estaré
por si me estás escuchando con tu
brujería y de repente resulta que la
cartera apareció debajo del sillón y
dice spanair a que estaba cuánto tiempo
desperdiciado pensando en algo que nunca
existió y así es la mente la mente se
acostumbra a pensar en el futuro en
cosas que no existen estamos con la
familia y estamos pensando en cómo va a
ser cuando estemos con la pareja estamos
con la pareja y estamos pensando en cómo
será cuando estemos en el trabajo y
empezamos a postergar el vivir el
presente decimos cuando me jubile ahí sí
ya voy a hacer las cosas que me
apasionan y epsa y ya voy a tener tiempo
y si ya lo voy a disfrutar o cuando me
gradúe cuando tenga mi casa
y se nos olvida que en una de esas
salimos nos atropellan y nos morimos y
entonces todos esos pensamientos
quedaron en el limbo que nunca existió
lo que sí existió fue esos momentos que
no aprovechaste por estar pensando en
otra cosa
nos tomamos las cosas tan en serio y nos
volvemos una versión que no es la mejor
para lidiar con las cosas llegó un chavo
con su mamá y le dice mamá me drogo y
entonces la mamá se transforma y agarra
al niño del brazo y lo va jaloneando
hasta su cuarto y mientras lo insulta y
le grita lo mete a su cuarto y le dice
que cómo es posible que le haga eso si
nunca le ha faltado nada en su familia
lo encierra y ella se va a llorar al
cuarto siguiente
lo más seguro es que ese niño no le
vuelva a tener confianza a su mamá en la
próxima y quizás se vuelva a seguir
rogando ahora con ese peso cuando somos
serios nos volvemos una versión de
nosotros mismos que no es la mejor para
lidiar con las cosas y lo peor es que se
nos encarna ese tono gris de seriedad se
nos encarna y aunque no somos eso se
propia de nosotros y entonces empezamos
a buscar excusas para
el por qué no estuvimos bien en cierta
situación decimos es que no estuve bien
porque me levanté tarde y desde ahí tos
por eso es que estoy así no es que sea
amargado no es que me topé con ese cuate
y ese cuate me cae mal sí y desde ahí ya
se jodió todo mi día o porque tenía
planeadas ciertas cosas y no las logré y
ya por eso ya ya ya estoy así ya no
puedo estar bien y nos empieza a
contagiar esa parte
porque llega a la seriedad la seriedad
llega porque nos sentimos demasiado
importantes porque creemos de alguna
manera que lo que hacemos es muy
importante que somos el centro del
universo
les voy a contar un cuento y es de un
hormiguero en donde había cientos de
miles de hormigas dentro de ellas había
un en particular que se tomaba las cosas
muy en serio siempre estaba trabajando
siempre trataba de ir enfrente y cuando
no iba enfrente empujaba las demás para
ser quién cargará más nunca descansaba y
yo no le preocupaba el descansar el ver
un atardecer viendo la inmensidad en
donde vivía ella quería que se hablara
de ella que cuando se fuera de ese
hormiguero todas las hormigas le
extrañarán y dijeran que ella sí
trabajaba en serio que trabajaba más que
las demás que se tomaba las cosas muy en
serio un día un niño de 6 años salió vio
esa hormiga y la mató con un dedo
qué pasó con lo que pensaba esa hormiga
que iba a pasar si hubieron algunas
hormigas que le lloraron por un breve
tiempo y continuaron con su vida otros
se enteraron y dijeron que mala onda y
continuaron con su vida y otros la
mayoría ni siquiera se enteraron en
cambio el niño creció se casó terminó su
carrera tuvo tres hijos uno de ellos fue
medio famoso se volvió cantante y nunca
en su vida se enteró que había matado a
la hormiga que trabajaba más de todo ese
hormiguero
este punto amarillo que está ahí es
nuestro sistema solar dentro de ese
punto está nuestro planeta tierra
adentro del planeta tierra está el país
y adentro ted coatzacoalcos ahí estamos
nosotros toda la pantalla vendría siendo
la galaxia la vía láctea lo que está
fuera de la pantalla todo este lugar en
donde estamos todos vendría siendo
quizás todo lo que se conoce del
universo es todo lo que conocemos hasta
el día de hoy todo lo que está fuera de
este recinto el estacionamiento las
calles veracruz méjico es todo lo que no
conocemos que existe todo el universo
todo es eso lo que está allá afuera
nosotros somos una partícula de polvo en
un punto amarillo sobre una pantalla
recordemos eso y no nos sintamos tan
importante cuando nos vayamos el mundo
seguirá girando consecutivamente como
normalmente no lo hace nos llorarán
quizás si por un tiempo y continuarán
con su vida saldrán nuevos libros nueva
películas vendrán nuevas personas
personas que de alguna manera pues hagan
que se olviden de nosotros vendrán
nuevas épocas nuevas tecnologías nuevos
videojuegos si queremos disfrutar el
legado no es el que nosotros dejemos
sino es el que nosotros disfrutemos en
cada momento de lo que estamos haciendo
esa es una frase que me acompañó que
dice disfruta el camino no el destino en
algún momento trabajaba para llegar a
una meta una meta de cierto número de
suscriptores y trabajaba día y noche
como loco para llegar a esa meta pero no
era pleno no era feliz me topé con esa
frase y dije claro al final no es llegar
al destino es disfrutar el camino así
que empecé a trabajar ahora con esa
pasión después de que leí esa frase
empecé a trabajar pero de alguna manera
tampoco era pleno no me sentía feliz me
topé de nueva cuenta con esta frase y
llegué a la conclusión de que el destino
al que yo voy al que vamos todos es el
camino a morir ese es el camino al que
vamos todo segundo tras segundo ese es
el destino final
ese es como como si fuera nuestra vida
una montaña rusa en donde están las
bajadas están las subidas están las
curvas están los tramos rectos y al
final tú decides cómo vives esa vida el
camino ya está hecho tú decides
la experiencia puede cerrar los ojos
puedes vivir con miedo puedes vivir
alegre puedes vivir en un caos de
emociones sintiendo y viviendo cada una
de las cosas que se viven a diario tú
decides
yo los invito a que nos rindamos ante
esa seriedad que nos invita a quedarnos
en una zona de confort de no expresión y
salgamos de esa zona gris y nos
atrevamos a sentir a vivir tan
vívidamente para que cuando llegue el
final de ese camino
digamos viví tan intensamente
tan en ese caos que hoy puedo descansar
en paz
[Aplausos]